all right everybody thanks for watching
or listening if you're listening to the
podcast on The Daily wire what I let me
just say up front parental warning
advisory hear that IIIi know some people
have told me they're like watching my
videos are listening to the podcast with
their kids and with their family which
is great because I try to be family
friendly as much as possible but this
conversation will by necessity I'm going
to have to use some words and phrases
and talk about some things that aren't
appropriate or suitable for younger kids
so I would if you got kids around maybe
just watch something else and then come
back to this later but do come back to
it please because I think it's an
important conversation all right so for
all the adults senator Cory Booker last
week provided us with I think a very
helpful but also disturbing illustration
of something he was at Mike Pompeo s
confirmation hearing Mike Pompeo is
president Trump's nominee for Secretary
of State and Cory Booker when it was his
turn to ask questions he decided to ask
Pompeyo about his views on sodomy so not
just gay marriage okay and that would
also be irrelevant to the job but no
this wasn't a discussion of well what
are you what's your opinion on laws
pertaining to gay marriage or do you
think the state should recognize gay
marriages do you think the state should
be involved in marriage at all all of
that stuff would also be irrelevant but
you know that the left Democrats are
gonna bring that up Booker took it a
step further and he put gay marriage
aside he said he wanted to know this was
his phrase what's your opinion on gay
sex he asked him in your opinion is gay
sex a perversion and Pompeyo wasn't
quick enough in responding I guess so
Booker asked him two more times in total
three times he brought up gay sex to
Mike Pompeo at a confirmation hearing
for Secretary of State
three times he shouted at him about
gay sex now first of all this is
obviously just a very thinly veiled very
very thinly veiled attack on
Christianity because everyone knows that
any serious Christian any devout
Christian who's familiar with his faith
and has read the Bible is obviously
going to believe that sodomy is
perversion because it says it right
there in the Bible multiple times Old
Testament and New Testament there's no
way around it this is it's just it's
right there there is no other acceptable
answer if you if you are familiar at all
about what your faith teaches sodomy is
definitely listed as not just a sin by
the way but sodomy is in the Bible
multiple times across the old and new
testaments it is singled out as a
particularly dire and grave sin in fact
there are only four sins in Scripture
that are listed as sins that cry out to
heaven for vengeance only four times
does that phrase appear of a sin crying
out to God for divine retribution and
sodomy is one of those sins okay so if
that's how serious God takes it and it
that phrase appears in Genesis which
means that this is not just a belief
held by Christianity but in fact by all
the Abrahamic religions Judaism Islam as
well but does anyone seriously believe
that Cory Booker or any other Democrat
would berate a Muslim about this a
Muslim is going to feel exactly the same
way he may even feel it stronger yet
that's not going to come up with a
Muslim only with a Christian because
this is anti-christian this is about
keeping Christians out of public office
that's pretty clear
but anyone who watched the confirmation
hearing you know they probably watched
it and they were hoping to hear a
discussion about subjects related to
American diplomacy and national security
cory booker just wanted to talk about
sex position positions and for that
reason even aside from the
anti-christian angle for that reason
this whole scene was a perfect also
bizarre and gross illustration of what
the modern democrat party and modern
liberalism has become and i say that
because the left in america is obsessed
with sex and obsessed with getting
everyone's approval of their sexual
exploits it it always comes back to sex
for them have you noticed that
everything comes back to sex it always
ends up back there
and not just with sex generally but with
i need you to approve of these specific
things i do in the bedroom not just
tolerate a proof celebrate affirm
everything goes back to that it's all
about sex everything's about sex and
this is where godless pagan ideologies
always leave pagan societies are our
debauched societies for a reason you
think about the ancient pagan
civilizations where you go to the pagan
temple and there would be orgies and
prostitution where sex is treated heads
as this kind of sacred right and sex is
also a sacred right to the modern peg in
the modern idol worshipper the modern
self worship for the modern leftist and
it's a sacred right because sex is to
them the ultimate pleasure seeking act
is the ultimate it is the ultimate act
of of finding pleasure you know not just
in life but but using another in this
again this is for this is from the
godless secular perspective with sex you
are using another person and kind of
dominating them and using them for your
own pleasure you have turned a whole
other human being into a tool for your
pleasure and so that's why it is the
it's the ultimate because pleasure is
the ultimate now to the christian sex is
also sacred
but for a different reason because it
bonds together husband and wife and
because it opens up the potential for
the creation of human life sex is
something that can create another human
being and for that reason it is so
important there's this dumb stereotype
that Christians are afraid of sex
couldn't be further from the truth
Christianity has this deep respect for
sex and it wants it but to protect it
what if you go to an art museum and you
see a great piece of art what why why is
there security around it why would you
put armed guards a security offense you
know why would you put that around a
piece of art isn't because you're afraid
of the art you're afraid the arts gonna
come to life and attack people no it's
because the art is a beautiful thing and
you respect it that's why you protect it
why does some why would someone go into
face art why would they go spray you
know graffiti all over the Mona Lisa why
would they do it it's because they is
because they really appreciate art and
they think art is so fun no it's because
they don't respect it they have no
respect for it they don't see its
inherent beauty and its inherent value
and worth so they deface it and they
defile it and they make it something
cheap and worthless in Christianity that
we in the church we talk about
consummating a marriage and everyone
knows consummating a marriage is what
happens when the married couple goes
back to their room after the wedding and
they have sex that's consummating the
marriage
what is consummation mean consummation
means completion it means bringing
something to completion so that's really
significant think about what that means
we say that a marriage is consummated
through sex in Christianity that it that
means that the marital covenant itself
is brought to completion when the
husband and wife come together
intimately when the husband and wife
have sex that is the completion of the
marital covenant that's what kind of
that's sort of like the lock that seals
it and now it is inseparable it's for
life so that's how Christianity treats
sex
not at all something to be afraid of but
something to something to respect and to
and to reserve for this holy setting
between husband and wife in the godless
secular world sex is just pleasure
they've emptied it of all meeting
meaning they've defiled it they've
sprayed graffiti on it
they've de faced it they've taken all of
value and worth out of it and so now sex
they've just boiled it down to the one
aspect just the physical sensation so
sex is just pleasure and nothing else
and and it's no other put so sex is like
it's it's similar to playing a video
game playing a sport watching TV is just
a little bit more pleasurable than those
things but it's no more significant than
that and pleasure is the point of life
sex is the best way to get pleasure
therefore sex is the point of life and
that's why they're obsessed with it but
it's also why if we're gonna talk about
who's afraid of sex it's not the
Christians it's them they're afraid of
what sex really is and that's why we
talk about you know that's why they they
are that's why we need to erect these
barriers and everything else and you
know physical actual physical barriers
that are used in the sexual act it's
because they're afraid of sex not the
Christians
that's why they demand that we affirm
their sexual habits not tolerate but
affirm and now they still say they want
us to mind our own business and you know
it's none of our business
but this isn't what you do if you want
someone top to mind their own business
if you don't want people talking about
your sex life you don't bring it up at a
confirmation hearing you don't march
through the street announcing it to
everybody that's not what you do when
you want people to mind their own
business and this is what you know what
this is the thing maybe in life that
frustrates me more than anything else is
intellectual dishonesty intellectual
dishonesty which is what makes most of
our discussions in society completely
fruitless and worthless and why they
devolve into incoherence within seconds
and they never amount to anything and no
conclusions are ever drawn and no one
ever comes to any kind of agreement or
consensus at all on any argument the
reason is because these are
intellectually dishonest arguments and
both people in the argument or at least
one person in the argument usually on
the left on the on the left side of the
equation they're not being honest about
what they actually believe in what their
intentions actually are in the
conversation so they'll say hey let's
talk about my sex life and then you'll
say I and I'd really rather not and
they'll say this is what I do in my sex
life do you approve No why are you
talking about my sex life this is none
of your business well which is it is it
none of my business or do you want to
talk about it it's got to be one or the
other it's the same thing with in and if
you don't want to talk about it's none
of my business why are you marching
through the street announcing I mean
literally announcing it to the world
marching through the street saying hey
everybody look at me this is my sex life
look why are you doing that a Gay Pride
Parade what what why you you have the
right that there's no more fighting for
your rights you have the right to do
whatever you want in America no one's
stopping you okay you can do whatever
you want
are you announcing it what's the point
if it's none of my business what are you
doing in the street waving a flag I
think you literally have a flag
representing your sex life why it's the
same thing with the feminists in their
vagina hats wearing vagina costumes
talking explicitly about their genitals
and then they recoil in horror if anyone
dares intrude in their private life I
mean you've got a whoop you got women
wearing vagina costumes holding signs
saying stay out of my business
I would love to stay out of your
business but look at you look at you I
can't even worse they demand that we
subsidize their sex life by subsidizing
their birth control so they say hey mind
your business get out of my bedroom but
before you leave put your put your
wallet on the dresser there because I'm
gonna need you to pay for this it
doesn't work that way
I'm sorry a couple general rules of
society number one if you ask someone to
pay for something they get to have an
opinion about it number two even if you
don't ask them to pay for it if you
bring up okay if you openly share
details about your personal life with me
I get to have an opinion and express it
and you don't get to act like you're
victimized because you brought it up
it's the court of public opinion in many
ways operates like a court of law okay
think of it like that at least as far as
this goes
imagine that a guy's on trial for arson
okay and in his past he's been convicted
of burglary well the defense team will
go to the judge and they'll say that's
his private life that's his personal
life that's his personal history it's
not relevant to the arson two different
things
this shouldn't come up in the trial we
should be talking about the arson
charges that's the discussion not this
thing that's in the past that's you know
it that's it that's his issue it's it's
Jerry doesn't need to hear about that
and the judge very often will say yeah
you're right you know what this is
well if the defense team or the
defendant then proceeds to get up there
and talk about it themselves well now
all bets are off you've just admitted it
into the conversation and so now the
prosecution they get to run with it
because you brought it up so what you
can't do in the court of public opinion
and also in in the in a court of law in
both courts you can't bring something up
or talk about it and then say well the
other side they're not allowed to talk
about this thing but I can know the
moment you print it up you have
submitted it for public conversation if
you don't want it in the public and you
don't want the public talking about it
and you don't want to hear people's
opinions about it don't bring it up but
this is you know people will even aside
from the sex issue you know in modern
society this is a common tactic people
will use it in pretty much any argument
you know you'll be talking about
something and you're talking just in
general terms about this issue you know
you're not using anyone's name you're
not speaking specifically about anyone's
individual situation and then what
someone will come in do is they'll come
into the conversation and they will just
unload their their own personal details
as it pertains to this general
conversation and they'll say what are
you talking about this is and then
they'll just they'll just give you all
the nitty 'greet tale nitty-gritty
details of their own life that you
didn't ask for and why do they do that
because they think as soon as they
attach their personal life to this issue
well now you're not allowed to talk
about it and they automatically win but
people will get upset about at me
because when they do that here's what I
do well now I'm gonna give you my
opinion on this personal detail you've
just given me then I'll say no I you
know what I think you personally were
wrong with this or that situation and
they'll say well how dare you it's none
of your business why did you tell me
then why did you bring it up I wasn't
talking about you specifically
you brought yourself into this well now
I guess we're talking about you I didn't
want to talk about you
but you talked about you and I'm not
gonna let you shut down the conversation
so now okay
let's talk about you you're wrong you
personally in your life that's wrong so
it's the same thing with you know if I'm
walking down the street and I pass by
strangers on the street I'm not I'm not
running up to the strangers and saying
hey what are you doing you're what kind
of sex do you like having III don't do
that because I don't care and I don't
want to know it's none of my business if
I ran up to you as just a stranger
walking by you know we passed we we
walked through the same aisle and Target
or something and I and I came up to you
and I said hey what what kind of sex do
you have at home okay if I did that you
hit you'll be well within your rights to
slap me in the face because it's in our
business but if you run up to me and say
this is what I do do you think it's a
perversion I'm well within my rights to
say yeah I think it is I didn't want to
know this information I really was I
didn't have this in mind when I got up
this morning to talk about this I'm just
trying to shop I'm just here at you know
I'm just I'm just trying to get some
groceries and go home you've brought
this up you have assaulted my eardrums
with this information about you I didn't
want to know it but now that we're here
and we're talking about it here's my
answer yes I think it's a perversion and
it's the same principle applies if
you're marching through the street
announcing your sexual hobbies to the
world declaring it I mean shoving it at
everyone's face I mean you're walking
down Main Street in a city just telling
everyone kids and everyone guess what I
do I get to have an opinion about it
and it might be an opinion you don't
like if you don't want to hear it then
don't bring it up I'll say it
the last time if you don't want to hear
the public's opinion about your private
life don't bring it up
Pompeyo was smart to not fall into the
trap and actually answer Booker's
question but I you know as I said if
someone asks me that
and I'm not being put up for Secretary
of State I don't see that happening
anytime soon but if someone asked me
that I would have no problem saying yes
I think it's a perversion if you're
asking me yeah I do think it that's what
I think so we know that the left won't
shut up about their sex life because sex
is pleasure pleasure is the point of
life
therefore sex is the point of life but
still a question kind of remains here
and the question is all right so you're
obsessed with it because this is to use
the point of life and you find your
identity in your sex life because you
can't find it anywhere else but why why
do you need affirmation though why why
the interrogation about sodomy why the
margins why the celebration why are you
wearing the costume with the vagina and
everything else what are you doing that
for
it's home it seems almost evangelical in
the sense that you're trying to
evangelize people into adopting your
approach to sex which why now but here's
the thing we're told all the time by the
left and they'll kind of scoff and
they'll say what yeah yeah we're not
trying to turn you gay when I try to
turn your kids gay that's not the point
of a of a gay pride parade is it's not
it's not to convince you to be gay and
okay I believe you I think that that's
not really primarily the point well then
what is the point now for Christians are
often accused of bible-thumping of
hitting people over the head with their
religion in their personal views on
things but that's because Christianity
is evangelical and yeah we're very
upfront we are trying to convince you to
be Christian for your own sake because
we believe that in Christianity we you
find in
the key to salvation and to eternal
happiness
and so not only do we feel perfectly
fine telling people about it but we feel
called we are called to tell people
about it it would be pretty horrible for
us if we thought we had the key to
eternal unhappiness and we didn't tell
you so you could disagree you could say
we're wrong we're crazy fine I mean
that's your opinion you're allowed to
have that opinion but you it doesn't
make any sense for you to be offended at
us for telling you considering that part
of our belief system is that through
this you find eternal happiness in
heaven so yes we are trying to convince
you to be Christian but with the left
with the sexual stuff they'll say no
we're not try to convince you to do any
of this okay so what are you doing you
have you already have the right to do
whatever you want sexually so there's no
sort of shortage of Rights
what why what are you doing I think the
answer is it's the same thing that
motivates anyone who talks too much
about themselves over shares dominates
the conversation with irrelevant
personal details it's always insecurity
the person who goes around announcing I
am so confident in my personal choices
in my lifestyle I want to tell everyone
about it that person is definitely not
confident because that's not what
confident people do a confident person
is someone with quiet dignity someone
who doesn't seek affirmation from the
world because he doesn't need it and the
feelings of the world are irrelevant to
him so I'll announce my Christianity to
the world because I do want you to be
Christian for your own sake but as far
as my personal life as a heterosexual
married male I'm not talking about that
and I'm not waving a flag saying I up so
proud of it I don't do that because I
don't need your approval it doesn't
matter I'm a hundred percent confident
in it and I have found fulfillment I
don't need it doesn't matter to me I
mean everyone in the world could think
that my relationship with my wife is
disgusting doesn't matter to me I don't
care IIIi really doesn't it's I mean if
everyone in the world thought that I
would think well you're all pretty crazy
but that's that's on you I'm not gonna
go talking about it I'm not gonna go
talking about it in the world because
number one I don't need your affirmation
it doesn't matter to me I'm 100%
confident number two to me it's an
intimate private sacred thing and so I
mean III I'm not gonna put it out there
for public consumption I'm not gonna put
it up there for public debate I'm not
gonna use it in an argument as a
bludgeon to beat my enemies with or as
emotional blackmail I'm not gonna
cheapen it like that I'm going to keep
it to myself with my wife you know it's
between me my wife and god that's all
that's the real reason you don't see you
know we thought people say well why
aren't there any heterosexual pride
parades I think for most people like
myself anyway it's because I what would
be the what would be the point there's
no point in it and also this is private
it's for me it's not for anyone else so
I think people are especially on the
left you know that people are yeah you
know they're they're unfulfilled and
they feel empty and they're not
confident and for that reason I pity
them and I've compassion for them and I
pray for them but point remains the
moment you bring this up the moment you
grab a sign grab a flag take to the
streets bring it up at a confirmation
hearing whatever else you start beating
people over the head with it shoving in
their face 24/7
the moment you do that well whatever
offensive opinions you hear as a result
it's your fault
brought it on yourself all right um
believe it there guys thank you for
watching thanks for listening I'll talk
to you tomorrow